Guatemala no tiene Cómo esconder la
basura debajo de una alfombra unas
20.000 toneladas de desechos que
anualmente arrastra el río las vacas
aportan el 2% del plástico que llega a
los océanos del planeta
la bióloga María José Hernández lo
confirma
este río es
ciudad de Guatemala aquí vienen a dar
todos los desagües los drenajes por eso
es un agua sumamente contaminada
peor que el plástico Hernández denuncia
que otros envases comúnmente utilizados
por los guatemaltecos son aún más
contaminantes uno de los grandes
problemas que hemos enfrentado es este
material el poliestireno como estas
bandejas vasos de un solo uso también
materiales donde vienen protegidos los
electrodomésticos como estos trozos
grandes que vienen a dar al río y no Son
reciclables
para minimizar el impacto en el río de
la basura de 3 millones de guatemaltecos
la ong biosfera GT emprendió un proyecto
ambiental donde trabaja con la población
ribereña
porque así podemos tener un poco limpio
el río quisiéramos Que volviera como
antes cuando habían mojarritas se podía
bañar se podía lavar tomar esa agua
en el último año se recuperaron 300
toneladas de residuos apenas un 1% de
toda la basura anual del río plástico
que se tritura en máquinas para darle un
nuevo uso
la basura que arrastra el río de las
vacas desemboca en el mar Caribe y
contamina las playas hondureñas un
problema ambiental que podría escalar a
un conflicto binacional se Honduras
cumple su amenaza de demandar
internacionalmente a Guatemala